hey youtubers is Charlie you probably
watch Game of Thrones when all those
awards but Danny Dave said something
really interesting about the spinoff
they're like we are not going to have
anything to do with it on the TV show so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about what I
think the actual spin-off is going to be
in how it's going to work with Dan and
Dave leaving Game of Thrones has now won
more Emmys than any other primetime show
in the history of television they have
two more seasons and thus far everyone's
kind of been back and forth on what's
going on with the spin-off but the big
thing that happened at the Emmys last
night besides them winning all those
awards where the Dan and Dave were asked
point-blank about their involvement in a
spin-off like are you working on it
what's going on with the deal they said
that this show they were talking about
the main show the current one this is it
for us and then just kind of said like
best of luck to HBO and whatever they
wanted to do with the property after
they were done with it so cut to a
little while ago at the tcas the
president of HBO said that they were in
initial talks but they really wanted to
just get through the main series but
they were very excited about doing more
Game of Thrones george RR martin
separately has come out and said i have
pages and pages of history i have the
duncan egg novels i have so much
material for Game of Thrones that would
be great for a TV series and even before
that going like way back to when the
show first started said that HBO was
like we would love to see ten years of
Game of Thrones at HBO because they were
working on the pilot getting things
ready to go and he was like that sounds
great I would love for Game of Thrones
to be on HBO for ten years so the idea
is is that HBO like the network itself
is going to do a spin-off but it's not
going to happen with Dan and Dave which
is like really good news if you hate dan
and Dave and really good news if you
like Game of Thrones so I feel like it's
good news for everybody even the people
that hate the show right now because
there are just a number of very easy
clear picks for what that spin-off would
be it'd be a prequel series number one
but they're just a couple really big
events that George our Morton has spent
a lot of time developing specifically
now there's like thousands of years of
history but some of that isn't as
spelled out as other times in history
like you have the dance of the Dragons
the Targaryen Civil War you have the
Blackfyre rebellion you have Robert's
rebellion so there are a number of
big conflicts throughout history that
they'll probably choose to Center the
spin off around right now the majority
of the people that watch the show but
have not read the books or just asking
for Robert's rebellion because they keep
referencing it on the TV show we've seen
some flashbacks so the like why don't
they just do a TV series for that that'd
be great they could cast new characters
younger versions of the characters that
we see now we can learn more fully the
story of Jon Snow's parents even though
I kind of like the way they're telling
the story right now the problem is is
that Robert's rebellion does not involve
dragons there are no dragons alive
during that time but the good news is is
that whatever time period they choose to
set it in fashion hasn't changed that
much the places that they live the
castles the locations they can reuse all
those things I mean obviously they shoot
it in a slightly different way just to
make everything seem unique from the
main series but they could reuse a lot
of the theme songs like they could still
use the rains of castamere as like the
theme of the Lannisters on the show like
anytime there's a Lannister on-screen
it's always kind of playing softly in
the background sometimes louder than
others but like the Starks have their
own theme the main theme song of the TV
show the one that opens with the credits
every single week they can reuse that so
they're just like a number of easy slam
dunks for HBO when it comes to prequel
series the real question is is whether
or not they want dragons on the show
because I feel like you can't do Game of
Thrones without like a really big
supernatural creature even even if
there's a lot of magic going on at the
time you still have to have dragons
involved in some way in the last dragon
before Daenerys dragons were born died
about 50 years before the events on the
TV show so if they literally wanted to
have dragons around like they have them
around now the spin-off would have to
take place before any of the events on
Robert's rebellion was even close to
happening so the only other workaround
to be able to do dragons and also do
some of the other big time periods would
be to make the spin-off in anthology
series where they just dedicate an
entire season to a specific period in
Westerosi history and it's like an open
enclosed story arc for that single
season then when they get to the next
season it's a completely different time
period with different characters which
presents its own logistical challenges
for a show this is sprawling is Game of
Thrones with as many characters in the
problem with an anthology
show is that you don't have as much time
to develop the characters so the
ultimate payoff isn't quite as big so I
feel like whatever the spin-off is going
to be it'll be like seven or eight
seasons in a single time period but
they'll still use some of the same
devices that they use in the main show
like you'll still see flashbacks to
other periods in time people will have
visions
there'll be an element of magic there
will be political intrigue they'll be
like a lot of the same elements that you
see on the main series it'll be a
different group of characters the
conflict will be different in the
protagonists will work in a slightly
different way like it's not going to be
the exact same formula with different
characters but it's not going to be like
a Battlestar Cylon thing where this has
all happened before this will all happen
again
the best thing I think they could do
would be to either do Aegon's conquest
if they wanted to go way back into the
past because they could do some badass
dragons you could do balerion the black
dread where they could do tales of dunk
and egg which would be more contemporary
but still you know far enough away from
the stuff that's happening on the show
right now that it could be different and
then if they wanted to go with the most
safe bet like the safest of bets they
would just do a Robert's rebellion
prequel so let me know in the comments
what do you think the spin-off is going
to be but for those either asking like
hey when are we going to see the
spin-off if it's going to happen what
they'll probably do after they're done
producing the final episodes before
they've aired the final episodes in
season 8 but after they finish producing
them is start developing the spin-off
behind the scenes so they can use the
final episodes of the main show to
promote the spin-off or at least let us
know when it's coming in what it's going
to look like like drop an actual teaser
trailer even if they don't have footage
ready but it sounds like everybody
involved is just committed to finishing
the main series first before they think
about what's going on with the spin-off
it's just the HBO has such a winning
team winning producing team aside from
Dan and Dave like Deanna and Dave have a
whole army of people that help produce
their episodes from the people that work
on it from the actual producers and then
you have all the directors the other
people behind the scenes and then the
executives at HBO dan and Dave are like
a very small piece of the equation so
they're the only ones that have said
we're kind of done with this I feel like
George R Martin would probably jump in
and get more involved with the
development of a spin-off and then they
try to find other producers to come in
and run the show but keep as much of the
current team production team together as
pas
of all just because they're the reason
for a lot of the Emmys the game of
Thrones is one so when you have a team
that wins that many awards you want to
do everything you can to keep them from
breaking up keep that family together so
I feel like HBO is going to do
everything it can to keep as many of the
Game of Thrones people on HBO working on
Game of Thrones stuff when it comes time
to do a spinoff but I wouldn't expect
them to tell us what the spin-off is
going to be about or what time period
it's going to take place in until
they're getting ready for the last
season of Game of Thrones so you can
kind of see Game of Thrones just makes
way too much money for HBO for them to
think about just completely dropping it
when the main show is over
so there will be more Game of Thrones
they'll probably more Game of Thrones
than you ever expected eventually but
for now the main mission is is just
closing down the main show in the best
way possible so congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner das Wolfen you
win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details what's going to happen next is
is tomorrow morning I'm going to post my
Ghost Rider
agents of shield episode 1 video ghost
riders debuting on the show so I
recommend you check it out it's going to
be a lot of fun they're crossing the
show over with Doctor Strange and a lot
of the mystical stuff in the Marvel
Universe this season so I think it's
going to be a lot better than previous
seasons but it's a 10:00 p.m. show so my
videos for will post like the next
morning just because it's so late well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to watch the season 7 teaser
trailer again and you can click here to
watch the first couple of minutes from
the agents of shield episode thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you